just to realize that I typed in the  wrong numbers at the end of the last  video when I was trying to put him in  the calculator we were trying to  determine the coefficient of  static-friction it's 50 Newton's divided  by 49 square roots of 3 Newtons and the  last video by accident in the calculator  I instead of doing 49 square roots of 3  I wrote 40 square roots of 3 so let's  actually calculate it again 50 divided  by 49 times let me write it this way  make sure we get 49 times the square  root of 3 gives us a coefficient of  static friction of if we round it 0.59  so this is equal to zero zero point five  nine and so that's it  I just forgot to I did the calculation  wrong on the calculator in the last  video